[Musique]
on est heureux pas vrai parfois je
regrette qu'on ne se raconte plus rien
que veux-tu que je te raconte
tu attends de moi des choses que je ne
puis te donner comme quoi c'est quoi
cette interrogatoire avec toi tout
devient un problème
[Musique]
salut ben alors connu SALUT MAMAN notre
couple est dans une impasse je pense que
tu vas voir un rôle à jouer
tu sais que je l'aime on se chamaille
juste de temps en temps
bon je tends la vaisselle oui
je vais partir
[Musique]
pas tout simplement partir au bout de 29
ans tu dois faire un effort si on
divorce j'obtiendrai moins
donc il vaudrait beaucoup mieux que tu
sois mort
il s'appelait Edward pas bouger Edward
viens Edouard
allez viens c'est bien mon grand elle se
moque de ma passion pour Wikipédia
en le voyant tu le laisses croire que tu
approuves maman il est amoureux
[Musique]
j'ai pensé qu'il y avait trois personnes
malheureuses et il n'y en a plus qu'une
[Musique]
on a cru qu'on se ressemblait à
tort
si je te reproche une chose c'est de lui
avoir fait croire que tu étais heureux
[Musique]
le chagrin ça va cinq minutes après on a
envie de passer à autre chose
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]